for a second night
people clashed with police after the
death of another black man
by another of their officers
peaceful protests turned to looting and
violence
at an already tense time for this city
body cam footage showing the
unfathomable events unfold
a routine traffic stop ending in death
an officer shooting a 20-year-old black
man they say by mistake
she intended to use her taser
father of one dante wright died after
being shot
by a single bullet
[Music]
his family attended a vigil ahead of
another curfew order
dante's mother addressing the crowd
my heart is literally broken into a
thousand pieces
and i don't know what to do or what to
say
but i just need everybody to know that
he is much
more than this the site of george
floyd's family lawyer here
perhaps said it all mr crown your
reaction to the death of dante wright
unnecessary just so unnecessary
this young man never should have been
killed by the police
that's why we have to get the george
floyd justice and police and
accountability at pass
just 10 miles away former officer derek
shovin
is on trial for the murder of george
floyd his younger brother
giving emotional evidence as the family
sat through more tough testimony had he
not
been restrained in the way in which he
was
i think he would have survived that day
amid anxiety over the outcome of this
trial
they're already calling for justice for
another will you be back tomorrow night
yes ma'am of course i'm gonna be out
here every day i'm gonna be out here
until they give us some justice
until they make a change i'm gonna be
out
[Music]
a here war of fireworks tear gas
and rubber bullets for many here this is
a story
they've seen before same story just a
different name
and a story that doesn't feel like it
has an ending
but it feels like the start of another
unsettling chapter for this city
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis